Salut à tous ! Bienvenue dans le TOP des clips honnêtes !
C'est le classement des artistes les plus sincères du moment.
Ils ont gagné 3 NRJ Music Awards, mais en même temps c'est normal parce que leur album est sponsorisé par NRJ
C'est le Collectif Metissé !
Sur notre single, tu vas danser!
Et dans 3 mois, tu l'auras oublié!
Mais tout l'été, tu vas chanter!
(TOUT LE MONDE!)
(TOUT LE MONDE S'AMUSE SUR LE TOURNAGE!)
On met du vocodeur parce qu'on sais pas chanter
Une chorégraphie simple parce qu'on sais pas danser
Mais tout l'été tu vas chanter
Sur notre single, tu vas danser!
Et dans 3 mois, tu l'auras oublié!
Mais tout l'été tu vas chanter
(TOUT LE MONDE)
(TOUT LE MONDE S'AMUSE SUR LE TOURNAGE)
4ème au top, il revient avec une chanson qu'il est le seul à trouver subersive :
C'est Patrick Sébastien
Toujours les mêmes mots
Le même acordéon
Dans toutes mes chansons, tu vois rien comme un con!
Et ça fait prout prout les couilles dans le slibard
HO QUE DU BONHEUR!
Et celui qui se place ex-æquo avec Patrick Sébastien :
C'est bien évidemment sa parodie toute aussi bruyante
Patrick Sébasteouchelateub!
J'reprends la même musique je m'suis pas trop fais chié
T'aimes bien l'originale mais t'assume pas de l'acheter!
Mais moi tu peux y aller car c'est du second degré
Et ça fais pouet pouet les glaouis dans l'calebard
Troisième du top c'est ... heuuuu
Houla alors ça doit être une meuf de The Voice
On vas attendre que le titre apparaisse ...
pffffff...
Ha ouais voila c'est la demi-finaliste de The Voice
Et dans un an on m'aura oubliée
Ho bien avant, bien avant! On passe à la suite
Ils perdent une place cette semaine mais reste numéro 1 dans le coeur de toutes les ados du monde
Et heureusement car ils sont là pour ça :
C'est les One Direction
On fais semblant de sourire
On a pas l'air mais on est décédé
On a aucune âme sans rire on nous force à chanter
Toute la journée
On finira dépressifs, animateur de supermarché
Toi tu sera alcoolique
Ou dans une télé réalité
On fais semblant de sourire
On a aucune âme sans rire